finally
am i back i think i'm back
i apologize for going offline there
hey there we go gosh sorry guys my
freaking internet went out of all
freaking times
for my internet to go out that's a lot
of fun
sorry sorry guys what's up abraham
what's up linda
intellectual jaden carter might die
today luis
what's up yeah what's up abraham what's
up jordan jordan door-to-door
what's up domino owen glover yeah we're
back sorry
uh no it didn't get taken down my
internet went out like a
stupid what's up thomas lambert
dellium uh i i am going to do this every
week daily
so yeah sorry sorry everybody it's just
my luck that my
internet would just cut out of that
perfect moment
uh hold on guys i gotta change my
thumbnail
because apparently it didn't load
uh maybe it did i don't know
no it didn't load
dumb i don't know how to i don't know
how to change that i don't know how to
change that
um okay so about episode three there's
there
obviously i can't say too much about it
but they're
it's very much like the first two
episodes it gets intense at the end
but uh but that's about it i'm gonna do
the same thing with loki i'm gonna do
the same thing for all of them
for all of them i'm trying to change my
thumbnail on youtube
because it is not what i put it
uh oddly enough i
i don't really know how to fix that
am i not live anymore can y'all yeah you
guys are here it's so weird
yeah so okay if you watched it you've
obviously realized by now that it was
super super super super crazy super
different
way different and um
i loved it i love how different it is i
i think it's great
i think it's really really really great
i think it's great how different it is
it's a risk i know some people aren't
going to like it there's a big risk by
marvel studios so let's let's look real
fast though
um i think it confirms mephisto j
electricity
uh i think it does no i don't have
spectrum it's not
not that bad um
right owen her accent is very different
okay so i was told at 327
at 327
it's a galactus easter egg
right there hey look at that
galactus's helmet look at that
wow
i don't suppose these spider webs are
reference to spider-man
maybe though but that is 100
galactus helmet
that is 100 galactus helmet
1 000 that's
crazy you guys see that right like
yeah you can see you can see this that's
insane i mean this
holy crap this is insane
so it's not galactus controlling right
galactus is going to be the big bad
he's going to be the big bad who would
win in a fight between thor and captain
marvel
for swan to envision oh that's a good
one i'm gonna go with one admission
hey thanks vic g this is yeah i did
notice riley the repulsor
noise during the toaster in the first
episode hey no problem
doggo bless you too
uh next week friday uh
friday is when the next it was when
episode three comes out
it's a very good episode as well it's
when the
at the end of this episode it showed
that juan is pregnant and the next
episode is when
they're born uh i think the big guy is a
sword agent as well
because the thing on the back uh yes it
is out ethan
um it's not glasses it's a grim reaper
grim reaper
i don't know looks like galactus to me
man but yeah we got a hydra strucker
easter egg in this one which is crazy
um absolutely crazy
um wow
wow um so guys check this out
so um
i'm gonna get on a zoom call now and i'm
gonna do it live with uh
soup and soups another youtuber
and this guy called brad who worked with
robert downey jr
so he's gonna he's gonna
talk about it it's gonna be cool um let
me see right now i'm just gonna text him
and see when he's ready to jump on this
because it's super cool this guy's
really cool
but these guys are really cool
but these guys are super super cool um
you know what it might be the grim
reaper's helmet i think it
you know what it does look more like the
grim reaper's helmet
so does that mean they're gonna bring
wonder man into it
are they gonna bring wonder man
because wonder man's the brother of the
grim reaper of grim reaper
so wow okay um hold on
real fast uh let's jump on this screen
yeah the toaster was made by stark which
is pretty cool one second
guys
how do i i don't even know what i'm
doing whoops
one second as i get with these two guys
we're gonna have a
really cool discussion here um i just
need to log into my email i don't need
everybody to see my password for me even
all that stuff like that
so
yeah definitely that definitely is the
grim reaper
it definitely is
i don't know what to do why isn't this
working
what the heck okay now it's down okay
okay
so i'm about to jump on this zoom call
with uh two awesome guys two awesome
guys
um and we'll have a full-on discussion
which is gonna be awesome
yeah it's definitely the what is the
green but who is doing this to you i
think
i mean it's i wonder what the grim
reaper would have
yes you can watch on disney place on
disney plus now i wonder what the grim
reaper would like even like
be doing like about like this
interesting oh roger wardell said that
hmm
very interesting
let's check this out
enter my name for the chat
all right i'm going into this meeting
now guys so let's uh
i'm going to show you guys this
hello i'm connecting i can't hear yet
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello i can't hear you i'm sorry
ah how do i
audio
hello hello
hello guys i'm getting worn on the
screen you guys can see him there
oh wait i can hear you now can you guys
hear me yeah yeah
awesome sorry about that all right
you're good
all right guys we're getting on warren
okay
warren you just watched well on the
vision
welcome bro marvel is here marvel is
back
yes yes oh man
and so much to talk about what a way to
kick it off right so different
so different so different than than
anything but can i just say and i said
this in my review earlier
paul bettany in the second episode was
fantastic
so good he's like
yo hold up hold up you're right they're
right
i just looked at it it is no way there
is no no no no no way
are the people it's 327. 327.
i saw it but of episode two
yeah but everybody is saying that it's
the grim reaper
and and i and i think it is um if you
look up the grim reaper or just grim
reaper wait like in the intro right
yeah yeah it looks exactly like grim
reaper's helmet i was freaking out too i
was like holy crap galactic glass just
galactus holy crap
but then everyone started saying grim
reaper and i was like wait a second i
looked it up and if you look it up right
now
it looks more like the grim reaper's
helmet than it does galactus helmet
it's like 327 but almost as vision
coming
he's coming down through the floor yeah
through the floor right
hold up
what the hell i don't know guys
yeah i mean it yeah kind of looks more
like oh my god
i mean bro they just [ __ ] that in
there good luck this is homie bro
what
oh my god some people are saying grim
reaper i'm gonna have to do some more
research on that for the breakdown
yeah and i'll definitely clarify for you
guys when we fish
when we cap off this stream it
definitely looks like grim rupert's
helmet
more so than galactus really yeah yeah
it does um holy cow
then they're obviously doing that but
they're obviously doing that yeah so
brad is my first time meeting you and
it's a pleasure
nice to meet you man i i actually uh
really enjoy your work
so much yeah i watch your videos all the
time oh thank you
i've i've been following you for uh for
a pretty long time on instagram on
twitter
or you just made a twitter recently
right
uh yeah i'm not super active on twitter
but ig for sure but yeah i follow you on
uh you know
on your red carpet with robert downey jr
and everything like that
super awesome thank you so much pleasure
to meet you uh i don't have
wonderful super smart camera is that
because his camera is being used for his
live stream right now
yeah yeah you guys aren't able to see me
but um
i could just i could hear you guys and
i'll have you guys pulled up on stream
so
yeah all good i i have i i specifically
borrowed one of my roommate's cameras
his his camera so i got one two that's
amazing
so but yeah guys we got a ton of easter
eggs in in the episode like
i know that i'm gonna go ham on the
break on youtube warren
um we got obviously the the baron von
strucker watch
um you know the the kind of like the
stark industries infomercial at the
beginning of the first episode
hearing like iron man's repulsor blast
in the toaster
yeah brad i know brad i know you heard
that and you were like
you're having like ptsd you're like oh
man you're killing me
killing me with with the iron man
team liquid merch on shot team liquid
gotta have it
gotta have it awesome
so brad have you did is it was just your
first time watching it
yeah yeah i just uh dove in man and
and i i was telling supes i
i love the mystery and the intrigue and
how it grows each episode and i can't
wait
it had a paranormal activity feel to me
when in in those films when the the
white noise and the static would come
and you would just get uncomfortable
yeah that's how it felt when
the you know she found a helicopter when
the guy was choking at the dinner table
and his wife was laughing and smiling
like you know stop it stop it it is a
very
uncomfortable feeling and that just
makes me want to know why
and what's happening you know what
what's actually happening here
um so i i can't wait to see if episode
three
takes it up another notch and you know
episode two had two instances with the
helicopter and the radio
episode three i want to see stuff really
start to get crazy
yeah um so i've seen episode three i've
seen the first three episodes
and i won't spoil it for people because
uh you know it was really weird like
watching this
and um like having seen it already
because it's definitely a different
experience um yeah yeah
to watch it for the first time which i
did um
just with my my editor chris and it was
it was really crazy because it's so
different but um
one thing i i want to ask you guys about
was
when they in the second episode when
agnes said
when they mentioned the devil twice
mephisto
were you talking about that dude they're
doing my fists
it has like so right it has to be oh it
has to be it
sorry and um and you know warren this is
something that we talked about
when you brought me when you brought me
on your on your podcast on your channel
you know mephisto this is obviously a
villain that
is going to be this is obviously some
someone that if he were to
enter the mcu he would be the villain of
doctor strange and multiverse of madness
but because the show is setting up
multiverse of madness
you know i i think it also speaks
volumes on the way they're building to
this story
and again warn remember the final
line of that episode of episode two
wasn't
wanda what are you doing it was wanda
who's doing this to you right and and i
firmly believe it
it's now it's either mephisto or the
grim reaper
or galactus but i do i do think it's
more grim reaper
but i i think it has to be
him i don't see any other way because
it's like
you don't just reference the devil
i mean like marvel right too it's like i
don't think i've
ever heard the devil referenced ever
in in a movie but i mean you know i
don't know
but to me that was just like and they
they did it twice right and and
especially if you consider the fact that
it's like
you know we all thank agnes the zag of
the harkness right you can't convince me
otherwise
yeah and then you know her working for
mephisto
and she's the one who said it you know
about the devil and she said it you know
kind of like like yeah that's like right
in your face right and she's like
i'm just kind of like um see
see if like you're not if you're just
like a casual watcher
you wouldn't pick it up right but like
because we live on this stuff
it's like it's like it's it's clockwork
we know what they're doing
and um you know let's talk a little bit
about agatha
or agnes i should say yeah because
you know we saw her in that first
episode i found her to be extremely
pushy
like she just wanted to be involved more
and more with rwanda and visions life
and then in episode two she played a
smaller role than she did in that first
episode
but again she she dropped something huge
she kept on saying the devil
yeah um she was obviously at the show at
the end
and um dude to be honest i think that
little bunny
like i i thought like when that that
little bunny was gonna be something or
like do something but um i i thought she
was gonna be more involved in the second
episode but she obviously wasn't which
means that
they have something bigger for her down
the line but they opened up the show
off the gates kind of throwing in your
face that this is going to be
a bigger character that there's
something wrong with this character
and she wants to be involved with one
vision for some reason
and especially during that scene where
wanda was cooking and she was literally
pushing her out the door and she
just kept on kept and kept on
yeah so what'd you guys think about
agnes
brad take it away uh well warren we were
talking about it earlier
how she kept bringing up ralph her
husband
and yeah and i i i mentioned to soups i
think it would be really interesting
i think we all expect doctor strange to
be in this 1000 per series
i think that's self-explanatory so i was
saying if
if most of these people are under some
control where they don't know what
they're doing they don't know who they
are they don't know why they're there
it would be kind of funny if agatha is
making strange her husband and then
talking [ __ ] about him
i mean it would make sense right so if
he's
if he's a prisoner of her in a way you
know for her to basically say he's never
around he doesn't do anything he's
useless
and if they're enemies i mean what's
better than to one-up your enemy in a
way and basically
say i'm more powerful and you're useless
um
so i think that could be interesting but
i do think there's a significance to
ralph
whether it's for sure somebody else for
sure they kept on mentioning him and
didn't then didn't show him
yeah there is ralph is going to be a
huge character 100
100 yeah because i noticed the same
thing brad i was like
and i i didn't catch it until the second
episode
and i was like where was her husband and
and then i was like wait
you never saw it and i was like that's
intentional because you see
everyone you see all the couples yeah
you see everyone's everywhere you see
everyone so i was like that's 100
intentional this
she of course means something we know
that already but her husband ralph
he is somebody so i actually really like
what you said brad that would be
awesome well i think that would be
really i don't think people would
would expect it and marvel is so
tasteful
in what they say what they do and how
they do it
right so there there's like we saw the
the chat
found either grim reaper or galactus
helmet
in the intro at a split second frame
right so like
to me like once again marvel doesn't do
anything
half-assed and even having struck her on
the the hydra watch i just thought that
was so smart man
it's just like just the easter eggs and
all of it kind of put together
i'm just even the the box uh the closet
that she was in to disappear
yeah it had like the mine stone on the
front of it you know and i'm just like
this just the
little details what make them so yeah
and speaking of the box that was
actually another
time that agatha mentioned ralph because
remember when they were doing the box
trick she was like
can you snap can can you put my husband
in the box yeah
something along those lines and um
yeah man obviously ralph is gonna be a
bigger character now going into the next
episode what are your predictions
what are your guys's predictions for the
next episode what do you think we see
so i mean warren's already seen it so
soups and i was talking about
potentially obviously she's pregnant at
the end of episode two so
she's either gonna get bigger or she's
gonna have the kids or both
um but you know time is uh progressing
very quickly
so i expect that to be the case in this
one pun intended
um so i'm excited to see what happens
but we're in color mode now which is
exciting
um so i think it's going to be fun so
we'll
know this episode without like giving
any real spoilers because i don't want
to yeah
for anybody uh is the brady bunch theme
yeah we moved to color and it goes to
like that brady bunch style
nice gotcha gotcha okay sorry i didn't
mean to interrupt you and um no you're
good you're good
um but uh going into this next episode
with the way things are progressing
this show you know warren me and brad
were talking about it we thought this
show was gonna start off
extremely slow yeah but dude judging off
of these first two episodes and you've
obviously seen the third
it's moving pretty fast man like we
still have
seven episodes to go there's color
wanda's pregnant
dude i wouldn't be surprised i wouldn't
be surprised if
she actually has the twins by the end of
next episode and
obviously babies i think that would be
definitely one of the bigger things the
next episode
and then with six episodes to spare
like dude you could easily set up a
wicked and speed
flesh them out in this season and have
them enter the mcu i mean
again if marvel does plan to introduce
the young avengers at some point
then this would be the time to introduce
wiccan and speed
so do you guys think we're going to see
the development of those characters
in this show judging off of these first
two episodes
yeah i think we're gonna see them at
some capacity
um but uh are we gonna see them grown up
i don't know um but it is going to get
interesting
with how quickly things are moving and
i'm curious to see how
quickly this situation falls apart
that's what i want to see how quick is
this thing going to fall over
because already the first episode we had
one instance the second we had two
third episode are things going to
continue to you know up
themselves um it's gonna get i hope
it's gonna get progressively worse in
that way to the point where i think
it's just gonna get bananas um and it's
already bananas
um and i and i can say that i i haven't
seen that far
um i guess minor spoiler
that they don't show that in the next
episode i haven't seen grown up wicked
and speed
um but i think
in one of the either tv spot or trailer
you know when division on them they're
trick-or-treating like their kids are
obviously old enough to
walk and stuff like that so yeah yeah
some degree we'll see them
at least like maybe like five or six at
least
right yeah um uh and i will say having
like
watch the third episode time the way
that time moves is like
you can't predict it um yeah you really
can't
get in the circumstances so but there's
one thing i
i want to get you guys opinion on so
it's been said and you know they haven't
directly said like yes this is based off
a house of m but they said you know it's
based off of
comics like really popular want to
describe which comics so it's like house
of them
so at the end of the second episode
where we see the beekeeper who i want to
talk about by the way
but when she sees all this and vision's
like scarce she goes
no and then it all like changes that to
me that was like
no dude such a reference and it was like
yeah you know the reality changes
right to me that was house of m all the
way what do you guys think about that
yeah for sure it was like her putting
her foot down like no
this is not happening and then boom
boom we go back in time and
dude to be honest i got like i didn't
expect that i didn't expect her to
to literally go back in time yeah i
didn't ex i didn't expect for us to see
that
i expected for us at some point to see
her kind of like
fast forwarding in time as we move out
through these generations
but i didn't expect her to rewind simon
but but here's the thing
hold on is she controlling time yeah or
is she just altering the reality
there's a difference that's what i was
going to say i don't think it's time
travel because someone actually just
asked that
chat too i think brad just nailed it it
because it's
whether somebody put her there or not
she has some type of control like you
said
soup she probably yeah for sure she said
no and i just so
here's the thing warren real quick the
the beekeeper
she was feeling uneasy with the loud
noises the helicopter crashed like
she was on edge she was hearing about
mysterious people in the neighborhood
so as a as a defense mechanism that was
me
seeing wanda say no one's messing with
my family enough
and and at this point she doesn't know
it's sword trying to help her
sure it's just these weird people coming
up into her space
and she was like uh-uh done yeah so
that's that's when she was like i'm
changing the way this is going and i'm
getting right to where i want to go
which is having a family
so that to me is exciting now if we're
going to
uh entertain the mephisto idea excuse me
if we're going to entertain that why
would he do this why would he manipulate
wanda
why would he manipulate an entire town
of people
what's the purpose and i'm asking
genuinely right
because obviously he's the puppet master
we're assuming
that he's involved and if he's
manipulating wanda and basically
who knows behind the scenes basically
saying you can create
your dream life and she already has ptsd
from everything she experienced in
infinity war and endgame
and everything prior to that with
sokovia so
she's she's mentally broken
so you know perfect target yeah and to
like play on that like to kind of
answer your question um i'm a comic nerd
and um what happens you know at one
point with like leading up to the house
of m
mephisto like impregnating her pretty
much right with
yeah and agatha isn't for mephisto or on
his side at that point in time
she is actually helping wanda develop
her powers more
but agatha does
erase the kids from her memory so she
forgets
them and that and then she starts to
slowly remember them she's like wait a
second i had kids and all this stuff and
that's when it
it goes to the house of m yeah so maybe
agatha is bad and i i don't know like
i've gone back and forth like is agatha
good or she bad
because she could go either way she's
been good and she's been bad
so one of my thoughts is either mephisto
wants kids
this is a weird way to do it but agatha
is kind of
his puppet as well right she's serving
him so she's
somehow in this reality and mephisto is
like i just want my kids right like
or something i don't know um for sure he
takes them back in the comics
so like i'd have to think about that a
little more if he actually wanted kids
but um yeah that's kind of where my
mind's at yeah and
you know when when we're introducing
kids of both wanda and vision
again this is another vulnerability for
wanda
oh yeah you know by the end of the show
we're gonna see her go crazy
i feel like that's not really a spoiler
that's like the inevitable yeah
and with her having kids now there's
more on the table to lose it's not just
vision anymore
it's vision and her family
and um i just think that's super
interesting and again
we don't really know what's going on
here on the broad scope and if we're
talking about mephisto
i think mephisto is fully aware of
someone like dr
strange what does mephisto think of
doctor strange what does he have planned
for a doctor strange is that has he has
he like encountered doctor strange
already
like what what is we don't have we don't
know anything that's going on
with strange we're gonna find out about
that you know towards the end of the
of the show or maybe in you know
somewhere else
but i think mephisto would definitely
have plans for strange
considering he's the one that's supposed
to protect the multiverse
and that's obviously what's that's
something that's at stake here and
again even though wanda is more i don't
know if she's more powerful than doctor
strange from what we've seen in the mcu
she's more powerful than doctor strange
but doctor strange is more experienced
and he's wiser and he knows how to use
his powers better than she does
yeah she's just raw power and that's and
that's what's kind of scary to me is we
saw her snap
at the end of episode two and put her
foot down like we said right
so she's getting manipulated like supes
mentioned where
we think she could potentially be a
villain in multiverse madness
look if she is tormented with her dream
reality
of vision her kids a family a life she
always wanted and
desired and then it's ripped away from
her
man that would send anyone in their
right mind spiraling and she's already
broken from everything that just
happened to her
dude and that's something that i've been
going back and forth with because like
obviously we have like the wicked and
speed like if they choose to do young
avengers like they could easily set them
up
but at the same time like i've been
struggling like going on and off about
this
how crazy would it be that like
she sees her kids die in this because
they're shards of memphis though
yeah i thought of that too and and brad
makes like an excellent point when he
when he says like
she's so fragile right now yeah just at
the end like i mean we saw her in the
end game
you know just sitting there thinking
about and and um
uh soups i know you watched marvel
legends recap did you watch that brad
yeah they showed a lot of quicksilver
there right it was all about
it was all about vision and quicksilver
because they're gone now
what it okay i don't know is vision
really alive right um
but but if that gets ripped apart too
then it's like i had to watch vision die
again
you know my kids got taken away and her
just emotionality right now and how
fragile she is yeah
easily could be the villain of multiple
and
soups and i talked about this the other
day and uh
we were talking about maybe
hypothetically speaking i i for one
don't believe vision's real right now i
think
either wanda created him or
this is what supes and i talked about
the other day sword
got his remains and is actually doing
experiments
that they should not be messing with and
that's darcy's role
and that's darcy's role because we know
darcy's in the show and she's coming
back as a doctor
working for sword would that not be
would that not be
a very important pivotal role to the
story for darcy
yeah bringing vision back yeah in a way
so
if they're experimenting on visions
remains and trying to bring him back
and like what supes mention if
if he's tied to this in some way and for
wanda to to win and and beat this
she has to kill vision again
and then kill her kids just think about
that to to get out of this
fake reality emotionally she has to kill
vision
again and her children
that's wild that's why i'm so amazing
dude like but when you think about it
when you think about it it's like
okay yeah that's enough to destroy the
entire that's enough to send the
multiverse that's enough to rip up the
multiverse into yes
shards like and that's why it would be
amazing
right i love how it's almost like um
joker
like by the end of the film i'm like
just kill them all like please i want
you to
it's you know what i mean so it must be
like that you know
yeah you would just feel so
much sorrow and empathy for her
and you're just like just go crazy and
what's interesting too
is is she doesn't have cap cap's not
there
to ground her again
and and keep her mentally there and
hawkeye is not there either
okay so like who's there to protect her
and guide her through some she's still a
kid to an extent right
so she doesn't know what she's doing she
doesn't know what she's experiencing
she's just rolling with the punches
but she doesn't have that mentor figure
that we've seen her have
throughout her entire life cycle in the
mcu yeah
and
and now i'm thinking like so now swords
manipulated her right
and she doesn't have anyone like you
mentioned
yeah i mean at that point you have
nothing to lose go
crazy do what you want right because no
one's no one's helping you at that point
right
the good guys aren't helping me the bad
guys you know are trying to
mess with me i lost everything no one's
there to keep me grounded like you said
i mean at one point you do you say screw
it right i'm
the most powerful being in this universe
it's gonna be my way
again like this show is something we've
never
seen before marvel marvel literally took
the biggest risk they could ever take by
doing something that's completely
out of their ballpark and just
pioneering their
universe and and pivoting it into a
completely different direction
seeing a hero like that just
descend into madness that's something
we've never
seen from marvel and again it falls in
line with what the show is all about
which is
expanding the universe and doing
something so different that has never
been done before
you bring up a really good point that
just clicked with me now
um obviously because we're all talking
about it but it was a huge risk for
marvel
um and i've had some people in my chat
like i don't really like it because it's
so
different and weird yeah but if they're
willing to do this
they're willing to give juan the kids
and then have her kill him
[Laughter]
i mean that's all i'm thinking about
right now if they're willing to take
such a
big risk there's no reason why they
wouldn't go further
look we have the mcu at the level that
we do
because marvel is genius at character
development
and what's more character development
than what wanda is about to go through
okay we're about to see a whole new arc
for wanda
and it's it's not it's not gonna be uh
rainbows and unicorns all right
it's gonna be it's gonna be nasty okay
we're leading towards the multiverse of
madness
for a reason and if wanda is the
most powerful person in the
universe as kevin feige has stated
she very well easily
can rip a hole in multiple dimensions in
multiple realities
so especially we saw her lose her [ __ ]
in
age of ultron when quicksilver died
right
so imagine what could possibly happen
with now her getting even stronger with
the training she went through in the
battle she went through
imagine what she could do when she
really blows her top off
that's scary yeah and i think i i
actually think that agatha's gonna play
a huge role
in her development and and like
literally
showing her how to become a witch
scarlet witch
i think she's gonna poke her she's gonna
keep poking her in the wrong direction
i really believe that i i think she's
there as like a
uh like a joker like you mentioned as
dare to play around
again i just thought about this right
now in this
weird alternate reality it's a secret
that they have powers they keep it like
a secret
they have like hidden identity what if
at one point
because agatha is so nosy she sees wanda
using her powers
she catches wanda with red-handed and
then she reveals to wanda
that she's just like her and they start
going back and forth
and she starts showing her how to use
her powers because it's not it's not
taboo anymore
because wanda knows that agatha is just
like her i i think agatha knows
everything about wanda at this point and
vision for that matter
i think she's there to pretend and
manipulate
yes
yeah i i'd have to agree with that and
like i said i've gone on the fence of
like is she gonna be good she's gonna be
bad but i think the way everything's
going i think she's
i think she's poking at her like brad
said
and you'll see some things in the third
episode um
where things get odd um
and it really makes you wonder they keep
the mystery it's real they're really
good at keeping the mystery
um can't wait yeah you know paul bettany
said the last three
what did he call it the turn or yeah
everything gets revealed
so you know i don't know what episodes
456 holds for us
but um
you know what
sure as we talking like trying to i'm
piecing things together
i yeah i i think
mephisto has to know about strange just
because
for sure and he's like you know the
master the hell realm
he is the devil right um
right he's reading all those books
he had the time stone and i'm sure he's
going to get out again
well that's the main thing he doesn't
have right now right now right
but that that is a huge power play for
anybody else
yeah strange
if you think about it you know
sorcerer supreme is gone strange is
still
young at the arts yes he used the time
zone a little bit
in his film and like learned in like an
accelerated amount of time
but he's really only dealt with two
things dormammu
which he was thrown into and then in
game
right with and all he really did and i
shouldn't say all he really did but like
you know he went through the future
which obviously takes something to do
but he's using the time stone for that
so yeah i mean if you're
mephisto and you're like i don't want to
fight the ancient one because that's
going to be a little bit harder than i
i want it to be and it could go either
way but she's gone now there's this new
guy
it's my time so who's my problem now
well if you can have the time
exactly ancient one's gone and the time
zone's gone the two biggest threats and
then you think about it who's the other
biggest threat well i don't want strange
teaching the scarlet witch
anything because she was clearly the
biggest threat she almost killed thanos
right that was very apparent
if you didn't she would have killed him
yeah and
uh yeah i think that's that has to be
what it is
right i mean they're just covering all
ends almost and mephisto's like
it's my time and i get this like yeah
i'll help you because i'll roll with you
right because she's an ancient witch
because she's been around since the
salem witch trials
yeah yeah
dude this is just this is there's so
many ways
like
the whole universe so
um are the are the mutants being
introduced
in the series
i think i think right i do too yeah
more mutants more mutants more more
mutants all mutants
i i i don't think it's going to be
intentional i think it's going to be a
side effect
of whatever goes down with this like
because she's passing through yeah
yeah through uh whatever reality or
energy or whatever and once again
if you want right so it is
gene exists at this point 100
that kind of creates humans by
activating their human genes
guys somebody snapped
i think that too because if you think
about how wanda
got her powers i mean she was activated
by an infinity stone
and who you know who experimented on her
hydra
what easter egg did we see in this one
hydra
there may or may not be another easter
egg in the next episode
i and i don't know what it means because
sword is clearly involved and
yeah what has hydra been doing all of
these years since they've kind of
crumbled
right so i don't know all that but i'm
with you guys because i think
since she got her powers from the mind
stone and
the snap was stateside
yeah and rocket i've always thought
this is a little off track but on track
i've always thought that
you know like you said brett marvel's so
specific in everything they do rocket
said it's like the biggest cosmic energy
that we've ever seen exactly so i'm like
yeah that means something maybe not now
but later and i think yeah yeah
right so i'm like and you know kevin
feige came out the other day in the
interview and they were like how far in
advance do you have and he's like past
everything we've announced five six
years
so when avengers and game came out they
knew exactly what they were doing in
phase four phase five
you know way into the future they knew
everything so
i would imagine they're introducing you
before
well i fully think they're coming in
phase four they're just not gonna like
yeah
address it straight on yeah
so who's the beekeeper just a
sword agent uh
the situation it makes sense that he
makes this
organization look menacing right
right stay away from me
right and that's exactly what she did so
what
stones and if monica is getting her
powers from one
who got the way i guess superheroes
or just like a group
like it's it's it's a
mutant of the frame because as if maybe
mutants
are just like the remnants of the people
who got their powers
and she's vulnerable and she gets
approached by someone whether it's
agatha or
someone else
i think all the all the stuff that's
gonna add
happening are gonna up up and she's
gonna have a full-blown panic attack
is there but he's not there he's not
helpful
you know he's just there
um so yeah she is very much alone
so it's going to be interesting to see
how she deals with this
issue by herself and kevin feige and
marvel have come out and talked about
that this show is going to touch on
mental health yeah and what makes the
most sense
is wanda's broken man she's been put in
a blender
10 different ways and now this is
happening and she may be going up
against the literal devil
mephisto i don't know guys
it's so cool to think about because
there's so many things that they could
do
yeah there's so many things and they've
already surprised us
by just how crazy this this show is
right
i mean it's literally insane and there's
so many different
i think i think brad's 100 right monica
flies through that red whatever it is
and that's how she gets her powers and
supes yeah i i i
and i don't know that it's not revealed
episode three i i wanna see
that because we that helicopter got in
there we've seen that
in the previews i wanna see that i think
that might be
like maybe maybe maybe
sword agents going
to infiltrate maybe going well how did
this happen and they're kind of
recapping it
right oh my camera battery died on my
other camera let me just switch it out
continue but sorry
but um yeah you're good but um
so so brad obviously we saw that
helicopter at the beginning of episode
two
yeah do you think monica was in that
helicopter
and that's how she entered that
alternate reality or do you think
monica is just like just a random person
that was
i i think it's very possible that she
could have been in that town before
before before it happened like she's
gonna and
she's not in on sword or any of that
yeah because
uh when when the helicopter entered it
was a toy size
so that that's what takes me away from
her being in the heli maybe she was
but them coming up through the ground
through the sewer system
maybe that's how they avoided the energy
and
you know the the bad stuff in that
regard for entry purposes
but maybe sorry to interrupt but you
just you know the point about
mephisto maybe making things seem a lot
scarier than they are maybe it's just
like a hazmat suit or something like
that right
oh 100 100 and then 100 percent bees
because that's why i was wondering i'm
like
he comes out of the sewer and bees are
like fluttering yeah why are there bees
like i was thinking about that
so maybe it's just like a hazmat suit
because of that energy they don't want
to touch it
so they went under it because maybe it's
just a dome right that's what i'm saying
and so yeah i think yeah i think that
might be a hazmat suit
and then mephisto is like making it more
menacing than it actually is because
he's like crap people are getting in
you're not supposed to get in
bees yeah yeah and it you know even
even with vision like i kind of feel
like vision is a puppet of somebody else
i i i don't think you know i i think
i think he's there to make wanda fall
deeper and deeper
into this fake life yeah but also
be there and not be of service and not
help to an extent
right because even when he saw the bees
like the b man like we know vision is
very strong and very powerful
but he was like a scared little timid
little
thing and even in even in in the bed
scene
where he was timid and scared of noises
outside yeah
and that's the thing like vision would
be the first one jumping in front of
wanda to protect her
like in civil war when the explosion
happened outside he's like i'll be right
back and he'd face through the wall and
go see what it was
like he he's you can't kill vision right
unless you're thanos but then god passes
him up oh and that's another thing
he doesn't have like gears
right so maybe like i said built
yeah maybe it's being being controlled
somehow i mean and and let's the mind
stone's gone that's not the mind stone
yeah no so that has to be
again it's just like a figment of a
figment or yeah just a fabrication
and i think just again because someone
else is pulling the strings whether it's
agather mephisto
they know that vision is one that's
biggest vulnerability 100
so if their goal is to keep wanda
immersed in this weird like alternate
reality
having vision and using vision as that
ultimate puppet tool
that would be the way to do it that
would be the way to do it it goes back
to my
remember i remember it was vision i
think it was vision the one that kept on
mentioning like
like for the children or just talking
about children in general right
am i crazy no
that was that was the line that the town
said about the the charity fundraiser
but but that's a very but that's a very
good point they kept
saying that which kind of teases the
whole once again
they say that ten times in that episode
and then at the end of the episode
what happens is pregnant yeah
well again another reason for her to
stay in this alternate reality right and
uh credit to randall granger i think it
was yeah randall granger
for bringing this up um that vision
could be like a puppet of wanda though
because in the choking scene
he didn't do anything until she was like
vision help him
and i remember like and leaks are thrown
out there and they're usually
you know out of 10 of them one you'll
get some good information from but there
was one where it's like you know wanda
is
creating the reality that she wants and
i think arguments could
1000 be made for that this is everything
she wants now it doesn't mean somebody
else isn't helping control it
but i mean he could simply be made up by
her
at the same time yeah i i agree yeah i
agree
but i also think like like i said that
i think mephisto still is in like
in control but he's manipulating wanda
to say yeah create your own reality have
your perfect life
blah blah blah blah but at the end of
the day he's still
pushing the buttons and calling the
shots if that is the case and mephisto
is the big bad of this
this arc um but i certainly don't think
it's agatha
i i think she's a very small piece to
this just like i don't think
kang is the big bad for phase four yeah
so sure
you know and mephisto is one of the
biggest baddest villains of marvel
universe like i mean you're talking
about the guy who like doom
can't beat ever and doom is one of the
strongest characters you know
doom goes to the hell realm over a
hundred times and can never beat him
grandma mephisto stronger in the hell
realm
but you know a villain that strange has
hard times with every time like he's the
big bad
like he has to be um i still i still
have hope for galactus i do i i still
think
he can dude but i don't think that i
don't think there's i don't think
they're really setting up one central
villain
i agree i agree i i think because
because again we've heard
we've heard rumors here and there about
them potentially setting up dr doom for
black panther 2.
yeah i mean kang is confirmed
mephisto at this point it's inevitable
so it certainly looks that way they're
introducing major villains that could
all
easily be thanos level threats like
threats that you literally have to
assemble an entire
universe to take down but they're
assembling multiple of them
so it's like there's no way to tell
who's
if they're really gonna focus in on one
villain like they did with infinity saga
or if they're gonna focus on like
multiple villains like there's just
no way to tell how they're gonna go
about it well i'm so mad that
when friday said something entered the
upper atmosphere it was captain marvel
not galactus but i'll move on past that
i thought for sure it was galactus but
um
i think i've said i said on that real
quick
on that real quick i mentioned this to
soups the other day i was like if you're
gonna have monica rambo
in in a show and then monica rambo goes
missing
are you honestly telling me that they're
not gonna call her guardian
captain marvel of course i mean is it
possible that we see
carol danvers in the show i don't know i
think it's a possibility
she she's the most powerful possible
that we see nick fury and again nick
fury has strong ties to captain marvel
well to be running
sword now too right that's what i'm
saying yeah that's what i'm saying
but is he but is he still in space
that's the other thing that's what i was
going to say
say like yeah you can call him captain
marvel if she's there
yeah so there's a lot of things there
where
i i was talking to soups about this the
other day i was like with these shows
the interconnectivity is is what's going
to make it work
that's what what hurt the netflix shows
is it was sort of there but not really
and that's where you lost a lot of the
the connective tissue
to this bigger picture so if they're
going to go all in on this
that interconnectivity with you know we
saw uh
the the police officer from ant-man
darcy's coming back
you have those characters that we've
seen in the mcu before
that's what's going to make these shows
work so i cannot wait to see
obviously strange is rumored to appear
in this i mean that's the kind of
interconnective
tissue that is going to make this these
disney plush shows
fantastic yeah and and that's the thing
that they've you
they've made strange so obvious
at this point dude doctor strange like
benedict cumberbatch himself literally
pulled up to the wall division watch
party
so like they've made it so obvious
that like for me when i hear paul
bettany say something along the lines of
there's this surprise actor that no
one's gonna expect
that we filmed with for one on one
that's going to be on one division
when i hear him say that i'm like i mean
everyone's expecting doctor strange so
who is he referring to
i agree who could potentially show up i
mean are we talking
i think dude i think well for sure see
quicksilver at least something a quick
silver
something like that something
but um it you know it could be any other
hero and we know kevin feige loves to
sprinkle in
and just make sure to let the world know
that these this universe is connected
yeah
he's he's done his due diligence at
saying that
you know um especially when he's like he
said it the other day you know he's like
oh some people are gonna
debut in disney plus but then they're
gonna go into the movies and yeah vice
versa movies and then disney plus and
stuff like that
um and brad you're right that's why
those shows didn't do as well
um and
the whole thing being interconnected
what i what i truly think in soups this
goes to your point of like
all of these villains coming in i think
and i said this in like a ton of my
videos anytime i talk about the future
of the marvel cinematic universe i think
10 years from now whenever
however long they play we get secret
wars and it's you know villains coming
together
and then all different versions of
different characters from different
universes coming together
and i think god and per doom galactus
all these i think we're going to come
together and then it's going to be this
this whole out battle because what i
think is wanda
is going to have that panic attack that
brad said and then she's going to just
break everything when it comes to
realities and then i think they're going
to start to collapse into each other
and that's how battle world secret wars
battle world starts all the the
multiverse
like collapses and comes into one and i
think that's
because how do you top avengers in game
well you put in two iron mans
two captain america and two three or you
know multiple versions of this character
you put in toby mugar spider-man and
ninja garfield spider-man and one
right i think we're already starting to
see it and i think that's why
we could have multiple villains through
this and then at one point in time
a year ago or something all these
reports came out that it was like
oh you know marvel's gonna have like two
teams like the cosmic team
and the earthbound team and those are
gonna have their own villains and
you know et cetera et cetera so there's
that possibility too because
you said something like uh you know the
most powerful
or everyone in the universe having to
come together to beat you know one of
the most powerful beings in the universe
and that's that's a
yeah because you have to imagine the
internals aren't one and done
right no it's going to be a huge movie
and they said that movie they're they're
going to replace
they're going to replace the guardians
that's that's what's gonna happen yeah
yeah for sure i mean there are deaths
talked about you know there are rumors
of deaths for
guardians three rocket and people so
yeah i mean
yeah and we know james gunn isn't coming
back for i don't know if marvel's gonna
do another guardians trilogy
i don't know i don't know if they're
yeah
like it doesn't seem likely that marvel
would pursue another guardians trilogy
when they have so much on the table
already like eternals fantastic four
mutants so i don't know if they would
pursue another
guardians of the galaxy franchise so
again now with the introduction of the
eternals
this is another very similar case to
guardians of the galaxy
a completely new team of characters that
again
is a risk for marvel to take to
introduce this completely
lineup of diverse characters they're at
you know at this point in mcu once
they're introduced they're going to be
the most powerful group of superheroes
in the entire universe
so it's gonna be interesting to see man
because
they're introducing so many people and
because
each each of these characters are so
extremely powerful like the eternals
alone man
they were created from the infinity
stones the two most powerful characters
in the universe at this point
scarlet witch and captain marvel were
both created from infinity stones just
like the eternals
so now moving forward i don't think you
could just have
one villain i think it has to be
multiple
villains there's there's too many teams
at this point yeah and then again
they're doing the fantastic four the
avengers
and the young adventurers and i do much
i think they're going to
throw all the teams together like you're
not going to just
you know in avengers 5 it's like oh
here's the fantastic four avengers and
x-men right
they're not gonna do that that's what i
oh i kicked my cat sorry
that's what i think is the secret wars
yeah it's going to be more like infinity
war where you have these
exactly little teams like yeah yeah
teams here and there you have the
fantastic four and x-men you have the
avengers
um and the eternals maybe but dude just
thinking about that
and just thinking like about a movie
where again just like
using the framework of infinity war you
have like
two separate teams of just major
characters
serving the story and um it's gonna be
insane man and again
coming off of the report that we heard
yesterday chris evans is back
yep chris evans is back we don't know
how long he's gonna stay
i i wouldn't imagine it's for long but
um
dude down the line when we get this
movie that we're talking about
there's no way that movie gets done
without iron man
and captain america i agree in that film
yeah
like we know we know we know feige is
too much of a nerd
to let him make that and for a cap and
iron man not to be in there
and and let's be real we talked about
this before how are you gonna beat the
portal cnn game
you have portals or dimensions open up
and robert downey jr
chris evans scarlett johansson everybody
comes back baby
and the house will come down absolutely
yeah epic brad why don't you call up uh
robert downey jr and we can fight
i'm on it well i've said i i i've always
said
recently i'm like you guys got to leave
him alone let him go
yeah let him rush other things and then
he'll come back in five six seven years
hopefully
and and be old man stark yeah and i
think
just what you said right there if kevin
feige goes up to all scarlett johansson
and chris evans or down junior like look
this is what we want to do you're gonna
be in it for like five minutes it won't
take much of your time
but it's gonna rock the entire real
universe
yeah they're not stupid guys they're not
just like just like toby and andrew it's
like hey do you want to be a part of the
mcu for five minutes oh my god yes
you know and again like dude these
people have families
and their kids are growing up in a
generation where every single kid their
age is talking about the mcu in marvel
yeah
oh so it's only beneficial for them to
be in the movies where they're that
their kids idolize
and um dude it's gonna be wild
and again right now at this point we
just gotta let donny rest but
the interesting thing to me with that
evans with with the evans news that
broke that chris evans is coming back as
captain america
is that they took a guy that swore
time and time again i'm done with the
character we did everything we could
yet kevin feige pulled up to his door
with an ark
that was compelling enough to bring him
out of the shadows
yeah who's to say if there's any matt if
there's any
man in history that could bring back
robert downey jr scarlett johansson
and offer them an arc that's compelling
enough to
make them interested to come back it's
kevin
feige for sure oh and
and and he's already done it patrick
stewart admitted he met with feige
right i mean yeah that's why he said he
you know
my character's dead but yeah and and i
get that i've retired the character
i've moved on i don't want to undo his
death but in a multiverse you don't have
to undo his death you're just a
different version of him and again if i
don't see hugh jackman as wolverine in
the multiverse of madness i'm going to
freak out i know right
missed opportunity biggest missed
opportunity ever because again like i
was saying like
it's these actors don't want to come
back because they have said goodbye to
their characters they don't want to undo
their stories right
logan is dead uh professor xavier is
dead logan was a
phenomenal movie in my personal opinion
and they said goodbye
and they don't want to undo that but you
don't have to undo it
so it's not hard brad like you said hey
you want to be
part of the mcu you weren't before right
you want to be part of it
like it's confirmed that they're already
doing that with captain america
yeah the face of their universe the
beating heart of this universe is
captain america
i understand iron man is the father of
this universe but like the heart and
soul and like the moral compass of this
universe
is captain america and he he you
couldn't have given him a better end
game an
ending in end game so now for them to
not necessarily undo that but to
continue his story in a different way
it speaks volumes on what they can do
moving forward with characters like
hugh jackman's wolverine professor uh
char perfect
oh my god what's his name what's his
name warren charles xavier
no the actor the actor patrick stewart
patrick stewart's professor x
like they can do it with literally any
character
from any marvel movie of all time
and it would be a smart move if they did
this should strictly from and i know
marvel isn't really in
and brand new no more than i would it
doesn't seem like they do things for
cash grabs
um i don't think they need it by any
means i think people are going to flock
to see their movies
but anyway i think they genuinely
understand what's going to make for good
storytelling and what's going to make
fans happy because vintage end game had
some fan service i'm not mad about it at
all
and i think they know all this they're
smart like
kevin feige should lead everything in
life to me
right like i mean
like did you guys hear what ben affleck
what ben affleck said about feige
yeah he was like again ex
expletive but uh this guy knows his
stuff
he's the greatest he knows what the
audience wants yeah
yeah and it's proven like it time and
time again
and that's why yeah marvel's made a lot
of money but they've made a lot of money
because they do it for the right reasons
yeah exactly
you know how to get this done like how
to make a successful franchise
over there at dc and warner brothers i
want to get into that because i don't
want to stress out we just had
i just had a great stream i don't want
to get into that but
you could different conversations you
could see what they're doing with star
wars and why star wars is now pivoting
into a much
more successful future they brought in
dave filoni
john favreau two fans genuine fans
who can actually produce content at a
high level and
feige is the best of both he's a
die-hard fan and he's a master producer
so that is the way you do it you put in
a fan and a pr
and a master producer at the head of
these universes
and they will succeed i agree yeah and
you know favreau speaking of him that
guy's phenomenal and he's on all
you know marvel producers as well and i
think
um feige you know since
the x-men before the mcu like i mean the
dude
is a super fan and just the best
because he's been in it for the best
he's the best if
you see this you're awesome yeah hey man
every premiere i go to i go out and i
find kevin
that is my goal at the after party and i
grab him for five minutes
we nerd out and it's it's a blast but he
is
as as advertised he is a genuine dude
he's incredibly smart and creative
and he's a fan and that's why these
movies and tv shows and everything that
he touches
turns to gold so as long as kevin's
involved i think we're in good hands but
on that note guys i gotta bounce i love
you all
i gotta get out of here love you guys
but it's late
but you take it easy and i'll see you
next week for episode three
awesome see you next week brother nice
to meet you warren absolutely brad
pleasure
please oops
brody so warren let's talk next episode
next friday we're both going to be back
here
sitting here talking about episode three
or you've already seen episode three
so i guess you know is there is there
anything else
do you want that you want to talk about
regarding these first two episodes
i think like i think we like when you
watch like okay okay look when you
watched it for the first time
what was like your your general like
initial reaction
my general in this initial reaction
first time
mephisto um yeah i just think it has
that dark horror tone
um because they they they really did
that
they really really did that um those
those
those just intense moments where the guy
is choking
and yeah no at the end of the second
episode right and how eerie it got
and just i just i think it's mephisto
because i think
the hell reference was was a big
thing i i think that's what it was and
if that helmet really is
grim reaper's helmet yeah you kind of
think of like
well you know death hell the grim
reaper's probably working for mephisto
right you know
something like that is is kind of what i
think so
my initial reactions were first of all
the show is hilarious
so funny dude i did not but dude i was
telling brad this that like i never
thought out of all of the characters in
the mcu i never thought i could say
that i could just sit down and see
elizabeth olsen and paul bettany just
do their thing and be entertained oh
yeah but that's what they did
we can see it we can easily just sit and
see anthony mackie and sebastian stan be
in a room and just go back and forth
but i didn't think i would say i would
say that about
one division and that's that's what
completely caught me off guard and
it was charming it was funny and
again we're moving more to like the
modern era but dude even in that first
sitcom episode where it was super like
50s retro
dude it was so charming it was so funny
and again like you said like when they
switch on that horror
and that just like it becomes really
eerie and it gets super serious
just that switch and tone again i feel
like that's what doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
which has been confirmed to be like a
horror esque movie yeah
i feel like that's what it's gonna be
all about and we're seeing elements of
that
in this series right and it's just gonna
you're gonna get more and more and more
and then like paul bettany said you're
gonna have like just a full on
game action the last three episodes and
then it's just
boom probably scarlet witch is
like a villain maybe not the main
villain
but i definitely think we could easily
see her dark
doctor strange which i think would be
freaking awesome to see
can you ima okay okay when paul bettany
says
that there's an action sequence that is
you know it has more visual effects than
um the effects in
endgame right i'll fight between scarlet
witch and josh
yeah yeah magic that that
that could get that job done you know
yeah i mean i'm just so excited because
this was such a risk but marvel did it
so yeah that's the future that's the
future
and i think some people are going to be
like
hey i didn't get enough in this it was
just kind of comedy to me
and i could have used a little bit more
of that dark stuff and i could have used
a little bit more of the story
but just hold on hold hold on
i can say the next episode
is kind of what we got in the first two
um so don't expect in-game in the next
episode
no no for sure but i think
hold on because it's about to get
even more and crazy than we ever thought
it could be because we never thought
this would be a thing
right and just like kevin feige said
paul bettany said they've all said like
this could
this couldn't have happened in a movie
they couldn't have made this in a movie
could only be done in this show on
disney plus
yeah so they know what they're doing we
just talked about how much kevin feig is
awesome and he's the man he knows
pretty much everything so i think
we're in good hands sit tight i think
we're not ready for what's going to come
and and there's some name drops
in the next one that just make you go
oh they said it and it's not like oh
i'm not gonna say it's like anything
like galactus or anything like that
no no no but but there's some and you're
just like whoa it just got like
intense i will say it's emotional the
next one's emotional and it's really
cool
oh really very very very cool yeah
there's there's some parts where you're
just
like whoa like this is pretty
like hidden it's hitting the character's
heart but it's also hitting me hard
you know um so yeah super excited so my
initial reaction to go back to what you
said
was this is like literally one of the
funniest shows i've ever seen in my life
i was
laughing out loud so funny paul bettany
like drunk on gum
in the second episode that that is my
life source that's so good
it's so good and i just thought i just
thought holy crap
like that's crazy uh what what were your
initial reactions they're very fresh
right now
yeah man um again so refreshing so
different from anything we've ever seen
before
and um i love that marvel is is still
innovating and taking risks because you
know people criticize them a lot saying
oh it's always the same generic funny
mcu movies
yeah this was extremely funny but it was
extremely different at the same time
and it was still family friendly and
it's still fit
their formula but it was still so
different it was so refreshing
and again seeing paul bettany and
elizabeth olsen just
do their thing like that was awesome man
and we've never seen that before and i
didn't
i didn't expect to love them
as much as i did in these two episodes
but i i really do
and and it gives me a greater
appreciation for both wand and vision
in like the greater mcu it really does
and and the great thing is is they they
did it
in such a different way that works so
well so well
so well and honestly they they
they're just fantastic together you know
like yeah like they click so well they
bounce off each other's
they bounce off each other so well oh
they do and then you see them in like
interviews and pictures and they're like
they honestly look like brother and
sister um because they're obviously not
dating in real life or married yeah in
life but yeah they cook so
well and i think what a what an
what an incredible idea to just come to
somebody's head to say that hey we want
to do this
and just like be like yeah
sitcom marvel alternate reality
both wand and vision sets up spider-man
3 and doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness
yep it's just it's so crazy and it's so
clever
it really is it's this is gonna win
awards yeah
it really is two seconds ali
d happy birthday shout out ollie shout
out so guys
so guys with that being said we've had a
long stream of watching one division
we've sat here for the past hour and
20 30 minutes just theorizing and
speculating
for the next episode which me and me
warren and brad will all be back here
for
hosting a watch party just like this for
next
friday so with that being said i look
forward to seeing all of you guys return
come back watch it with us and then
speculate and theorize
with us for the next episode yes with
that being said thank you guys for
tuning in to this live stream more than
any final thoughts
this was a lot of fun i'm glad we did so
much fun man so much fun
uh dude besides the water mission stuff
like just sitting here and like nerding
out together after this stuff is just
this is something you can't get with the
movies no and that's what i was thinking
i was like you know if this was a movie
premiere
i'd go to the movie and then i'd be
running home to go do a video
and like you know what i mean i'm like
this is so nice to get to talk with two
awesome people uh
who i respect guys if you're not sub to
subs you need to
go do it right now um go sub to lauren
cosmic wonder yeah go sub to him right
now um
it's just it was so much fun the the
show was amazing
and i don't know just it's a great time
to be live right now you know
a great time sucked but i mean this is a
really good way to
to start off 2021 and i'm grateful for
you uh for brad for
all the awesome people in the chat right
now that support all of us youtubers
like
let us live our dreams and it's just
awesome it's a dream come true
1 000 so with that being said guys
marvel's back it's so happy to finally
i'm so happy to finally say that
marvel is back marvel's back
let's go this war has begun we're in it
yes sir
it's phase four now frick
oh my god this is gonna be this is gonna
be a crazy journey man and i'm so
excited to
experience all of this from the
beginning with warren and brad with you
guys watching
because it's only going to get we're
going to come back to streams like this
yeah and when it's all said and done
yeah and say
damn look at us for real what were you
thinking me and
you're gonna be like sitting next to
kevin feige and be like you know we used
to do like these streams till six in the
morning
literally screaming screaming
assembling the world on these streams at
three in the morning right
so hey it's what we love
that's why we're all here right now it's
what we love so
i think it might be time for some sleep
yes sir
or i'm not sleeping for the next couple
days bro there's so much to create i
know so
i'm gonna go get some making videos but
thank you guys for watching thank you
warren for joining us again we'll be
back here
next week to watch episode three and
break it all down
so guys with that being said thank you
guys for tuning into this live stream i
love you guys three thousand and we'll
see you guys next time
see you soon peace
all right guys wow that was uh
that was a lot i don't get the benad i
don't get it i've been seeing it sorry
i've been trying to
be respectful to everybody else i'm not
sure i get it
can somebody explain it to me
ultron sucks isn't the credit scenario
it's just an actor or something i don't
know about
please tell will ultron ever return
i can't say
[Music]
i love you 3002 thomas lambert uh
so i love you 2002 subba see das
you guys are all awesome it's very late
here
and i have uh videos to make uh thoughts
on
flukkum thoughts of dr doom
and ghost ryder being connected to
mephisto um i think
mephisto and dr doom have
probably one of the biggest biggest
connections
and uh suma bardwash love you too
um
i think the biggest connection
would be between dr doom and mephisto um
if you've read the comics
doom his mother gets taken to the hell
dimension
and is basically held prisoner by
mephisto
and doom he
goes and he and basically
mephisto says that if you can beat me
you can have your mother back
and doom to this day has not
beat him in the comics that i'm aware of
unless something new came out recently
that
that i don't know about um
but to this day he hasn't he even
mephisto even i'm sorry uh dr doom even
teamed up
with doctor strange at one point to go
to the hell dimension
and fight mephisto to get doctor doom's
mother back
and cynthia von doom is is still
kind of in the hell dimension she she
moved up she's not quite yet in the
world
she she moved out of the hell dimension
but but but she
she's still stuck in another realm um
hey thanks geek studios it was a lot of
fun i'm so tired
it's 327 for me and i think it's like 5
27
for you know people on the east coast
and uh it's very late but this was a lot
of fun guys i hope everybody enjoyed it
same thing next friday i'm going to get
working on some videos i'm going to
drink
all of the energy right now uh
i do have my own code for g fuel
if you want to use could cosmic if
people like energy drinks and this uh g
feels a little bit more healthy
but i'm going to be doing all the energy
drinks right now and be making some
videos so
tomorrow i'm going to do breakdown of
episodes 102
that we just saw uh talk about the most
important things
that we saw tonight the most important
thing so i loved one division
i hope everybody loved it as well i've
seen episode three already
it's very good i think people are going
to to really really like it
and um i think this i don't think we're
ready for what
for what the final three episodes 789
hold for us in uh in one division
i don't think we're ready i i think it's
going to be crazy
but i i'm ready but i'm not ready for it
so
you're right max it's not worth sleeping
right now um
and that's why i'm not going to i'm just
going to bust out some videos and then
i'll sleep all
day tomorrow so um
yeah this is a ton of fun guys uh is the
first time i've done something like this
on my youtube channel
and i love that you are all here for it
i love that we can all
geek out together i hope you guys liked
uh the chat with brad
who is awesome and he's worked with
robert downey jr kevin feige he he's a
he's a huge guys and he's a super cool
guy and supes is awesome too
um so next week we'll get back together
again uh we'll do
the watch party where we all watch it on
our own
as you saw i can't uh i can't show it on
my screen unfortunately maybe one day
i'll get to uh
maybe i'll get to be that big where i
can disney lets me uh put it on my uh
my stream but i will be watching next
week next friday
same time it'll be 12 01 am
pacific time 301 am
eastern time in the united states so i'm
gonna go get
i'm gonna go get working i appreciate
everybody who stopped by today
thank you all uh yes i do have a discord
server
uh you can find it i think in the about
me section of
my youtube channel so thank you all so
much this
is awesome i love you all i'm so glad
that you all support my channel
and actually like my content i never
thought people would
it's kind of a surreal thing i was just
a nerd talking about
movies that he liked and then comics
that he liked and uh
it's it's this now where i get all of
you who are just
awesome and i can't be i couldn't be
more grateful
i love you guys and we're gonna
be back here friday but look out for my
videos tomorrow hope everybody
enjoyed one division i'll see you all
next time